[Music]
yo man what's up what's up listen we're
here in front of the saint louis chess
club and uh it's the world famous club
as you know we live here all the time
but there are great clubs all around the
world absolutely and uh i gotta say
there's a great club in new york city
yeah for sure i just played on a lot of
them you got to talk new york city the
marshall chess club i was champion of
the marshall chess club let me just
humble no right
absolutely uh you know that club was
pretty strong and somehow i managed to
win a championship there
but
the importance of clubs
for chess especially now
in the digital age
yeah
in the past that you couldn't overstate
the importance of the club the club
was the place it's the hub man that's
where everybody went that's where we
talked to each other do you know about
the russian championships you got the
bulletins we traded books we traded
stories we analyzed we played so the
clubs
especially in the 70s 80s 90s man that
was the gathering place and in
on the west coast we had a marvelous
club the mechanics chess club san
francisco i've been there did lectures
played there
and
that club from the 1850s
right still a vibrant place today that's
like a marvelous place in new york what
was your favorite hangout well you know
like you said without the clubs
how do you find players exactly i
remember going to the manhattan chess
club the manhattan chess club no longer
exists now
it was an institution in fact the
manhattan moved into the carnegie hall
building exactly like you know you're on
the tenth floor when you arrive
as a musician you go to carnegie hall of
course when you arrive at the chess
player you go to the manhattan chess
club exactly
i remember going into the manhattan club
and you you've got all these famous
grand masters in there and we'd have
friday night blitz right and i would
have played in those two i would walk in
right and i remember once i walked into
the friday night blitz and you know
there was uh steve emmett the tournament
director and i said jeffrey kastner no
in particular i remember steve inman
when i walked in and i said to steve
who's playing in the blitz tonight
and he says to me no he says to me you
can't ask who's playing in the blitz and
then not play he thought i was trying to
you
know
get a fast one hustle right i said to
him
i only want to play if there's strong
players playing
and he's shot he said well we've got
benjamin we've got fed we got deluge
yesterday sign me up yeah i mean that's
the kind of strength level you had at
that club you always wanted to play so
it allowed me to get stronger as a
player if there were no clubs there was
no internet and stuff to to
be able to just jump on and get a strong
player anytime you want you needed a
club in order to make that happen no
question about it and for me
and seattle when i was growing up we had
the american chess service the acs and
we had a guy organizer there's always
one organizer who is you know like there
all the time robert anthony carter we
called him rack
and rack organized tournaments i am not
kidding nearly every weekend
congresses i remember playing in these
you know any kind of holiday there was a
thanksgiving day tournament there was a
columbus day tournament there was a
president's day open you know all of
these tournaments and that's where i got
strong that's where i cut my teeth and
you know sharpened my game and
where i actually met all my friends now
today you want to talk about a digital
age like ah
it's it's all online which has been good
in many ways but i miss this
the camaraderie at the club move you
know i'm thinking about i'm thinking
about old school clubs
like the flea house oh brilliant you
know my my good homeboy willie johnson
and pop he's telling me about the days
in the fleet house where he's coming up
he see uh ginger josh really hanging out
and those players you know about the
fleet house oh gosh yes
okay i go there in 1977 i'm 17 years old
as strong as an ox surfer swimmers build
long hair
afro actually here
come in
and the guy says to me you look like
you're looking for something what are
you looking for
it's in a chess game
social or for money
i play for a little money come with me
brings me to the table
guys guys holding court
got a new customer says the guy says
where you from i go seattle
go seattle
that's close to alaska
alaska
gets night out
understand me
at that exact moment in my life
there was one possibly two people in the
entire united states who could play even
with me they were walter brown and
bernard zuckerman and that was it
everybody else if i don't recognize
bernard zuckerman or walter brown you're
toast
guys giving me night off it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable i don't
know what i did marie seriously i was
just like lollygagging and i don't know
because there were side bets going on i
got confused i lost the game
what the last game was knight odds
game
the best thing i could possibly do
everybody jumped on the next game i
wiped them out wiped them out wiped them
out we played even but he gave me time
odds three to one i wiped them out wiped
them out we played even three to three i
wiped him out wiped him out i gave him
three to one
he says come tomorrow
i show up the next day asa hoffman comes
that's their champion asa took one
no we're going out to dinner i'm going
to teach you treat you raise pizza
you're going to wipe me out
and everybody in the flea house
he's a kid
that's an
of a club that is very little known the
kingsman chess club do not know the
kingsman chess club were a group of
largely african-american players in
brooklyn i ended up growing up with
people who were from the kingsman chess
club the black bear school yes but the
kingsman chess club they were some
serious players and as a
young expert budding master i would play
against these guys and
john evans i remember uh
of course willie johnson was a part of
it and the lights
and it was because of a club like that
that you could go to that you could say
here's a serious player right here
people you could sit down it wasn't just
blitz it was even over the board but
casual over the board right you don't do
that nowadays nobody sits down and plays
games without clocks and time no no way
in the world but it was a place like
that where i could go and grow as a
young african-american in brooklyn right
without that club
i don't graduate and add to everything
you said you play a wonderful game
and then the guy says no man i was doing
great let's just i should have played
this
and you analyze and the next thing you
know you start appreciating the fact
that you missed ideas somebody else
spectators come in and they go no no no
that was fun yeah the fun part of course
is as you said the kabitsu is on the
side hey why didn't you do this
everybody's 200 points stronger when
they're on the side and they're just
talking and you're you know what what do
you mean this and that and that kind of
camaraderie how do you find it in a
digital age you just don't it's
that is a lost art yeah and i used to
love that about the analysis everybody's
hands on the board right you got to have
rules now you can't put your hand if you
touch the board you got to put money you
have to put money
forget about it right that's the kind of
stuff you just miss when you're always
doing it on a computer online no
question about it that
that's the downside there was one
downside of a club i just got to mention
i had a club that i went to uh and i
cycled to the club
and frankly speaking it was 20 minutes
to get to the club but that was downhill
it was an hour coming back
up the hill you get to the club and
there was nobody to play oh that's
that's the tough part i agree nobody to
play the digital age is quite different
you always have somebody that's exactly
and it's a great thing to have some
place like the st louis chess club oh my
goodness where everyone can come
and enjoy a game and the best part
there's people like yeah sarah on
maurice ashley a christian carrillo and
alejandro ramirez grandmasters
everywhere absolutely
always nice always nice
let's play let's play
e4 you don't play
oh man this is getting this is getting
good right okay
chinese variance no i don't know that
stuff yeah that's too modern
[Music]